it would seem that they are laying the
basic groundwork for removing Joe Biden
and they're going to bring someone else
in now there have been many hints each
little grain of grain of sand being
added to the heat we had a report from
axios over a month ago about how
Democrats were lining up alternates but
now we have Joe Biden himself saying if
it weren't for Donald Trump he wouldn't
even be running again which is an
interesting suggestion considering that
Donald Trump is facing prison and facing
other means by which they're going to
try to stop him from running I believe
this story right here this is Joe Biden
on a fundraising C fundraising campaign
Trail suggesting he doesn't even want to
run it's only because of trump which
opens the door down the line for a clean
e a clean exit now we don't know exactly
how it's going to happen but uh nobody
really thinks that Joe Biden is going to
run some people do to be fair but
realistically how's this going to play
out